he has made his own rules clearly and
and and
he there were times where I think I
don't understand what he's doing but
some of this may act may actually work
to his benefit in certain ways for
example then it's all over the news
right now that he has invited Kim
jong-un he's saying he's saying I'd be
honored to meet with it honored honored
to meet which is a very strange thing to
say and then do Duterte the guy in the
Philippines yeah it early just once -
he's murdered Journal as it has admitted
murdered that he's a murderer dealers he
kills people right and Trump has invited
him to meet with him and I think I don't
understand it but you sometimes think it
does it in some way is it just so
outside our box that there's a
possibility that he might accidentally
do something good everything with Trump
in this case you have to understand him
the person he he thinks he can have
everything with him is personal
transaction right everything is personal
transaction I'm sure everybody in this
if you've had any interactions yes and
when the camera's not on he's
extraordinarily charming yes he wants to
be and he thinks that he can he thinks
he can convince anybody of anything just
give him five minutes he my experience
with him back in the day was I got the
sense that he very much wants to be like
this has been said by many people so
this is no revelation but he wants to be
liked and that he'll talk this way but
if you went up to him and then just said
hey after he let's say you just insulted
him but and then you said to him by the
way I like you sue he might say hey
thanks a lot I like your suit to bet he
wants to connect oh wait don't like that
and then he might like keep track of
that and then send you a note here's
where I got my suit right and I called
the guy and I mean so there's this that
there's that aspect of them in any any
yearns for that look on North Korea it's
not as if what Bush and Obama did worked
right so and and you know if somehow in
five years he somehow can we get to a
point where North Korea is letting
people in inspecting the nukes and it
was nothing well alright it was a
different strategy but it might have
worked right I or thermonuclear war
right one of the other always end on a
laugh yeah
[Applause]
you